right this new AI thing is even like
more sort of whoa we're talking about
intelligence itself man we're talking
about something that is it's you know
every day like you said like in three
months it's just and so that feeling
interior wow we're not prepared to deal
with this you have to have symmetry
between wisdom and power at a minimum
and if we're looking at a magnitude of
power over here let's just call it X
then what does it look like to
constitute something that has a
magnitude of wisdom at least slightly
more than x right let's just hold that
as the problematic in the Bible there's
literally a story like the story of
Solomon is about that the story of
Solomon is about God asks him what he
wants if God acts as a Genie in this
situation God says what is your wish
Solomon what do you want one thing tell
me what you want I'll give it to you and
then Solomon says I want wisdom
then what does he do he builds the
temple he makes a technical space but he
does it after he's asked for wisdom so
because of it it's sacred it's a Sacred
Space now we're in the opposite
direction like now we're we basically
made a deal with the devil we've got all
these these things that are massively
powerful and now we're like oh we should
have asked for wisdom it's too late what
do we do now it's like
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
when it Kobe did it I was just like yeah
you want to come here sure sure and so
just basically been traveling Non-Stop
and
so how about you so what are you working
on these days
well a lot of my energy is now turning
into the AI space yeah
um you know my my sort of basic mode has
been
sitting at uh sort of a a high point
watching I guess you could call it kind
of global systemic risk or something
like that which includes the way our
individual and Collective mentality
thinks about such things yeah
um and all the different institutions
and organizations and paradigms and
models that we use to think about such
things you can think about all those and
just keeping an eye on it so like when
covet came I sort of rotated to the
Whiteboard and said oh Global pandemic
expected in this time window check here
it is now let's start watching how it
plays out and so my attention sort of
moves from a highly diffuse nothing
particularly pressing going on and go
back to the big picture to the oh one of
the big things is happening so with llms
popping last year and then in particular
over the last six months
a large number of people that I have
collaborated with in the past have come
in and said hey let's focus on this
problem with AI so that's become quite
uh
dominant amount of time and attention
over the past few months yeah and so and
so for those that are watching this
that's the reason why Jordan and I
decided to to talk was to talk about the
question of agency transpersonal agency
the relationship with AI and all that so
it's so so it's it's definitely an
important thing it's weird I'm in the
weird spot because in I've been talking
about this problem for a few years now
like the the problem of
of AI uh and how it's related to
to whatever to something like
transpersonal agency uh and so now that
it's exploding and everybody's talking
about it I actually kind of I've
actually stopped talking about it but I
think this is the right this is the
right time to to restart the
conversation uh and so what is your
diagnostic like what what do you see as
the the situation because I don't know
if you watched you I mean you talk to
John ravaki he clearly has now made his
position pretty clear and so I'd
definitely like to hear yours yeah and
he and I have talked about that I
actually had an opportunity to meet with
him over Easter nice particularly good
timing
um just before he created that video and
we had a good institution about it so I
have um
sort of intimate Clarity on what he's
thinking about
radically intimate I don't know him that
well than once but still
well let me put it let me put it this
way
um
thank you
I'm Jonathan Pedro and I'm inviting you
to participate with us in our retelling
and our celebration of one of the most
iconic fairy tales of all Snow White
a beautifully Illustrated storybook Snow
White and the Widow Queen places our
iconic character at the beginning of
eight upcoming fairy tales which will
speak to each other and harmonize in
surprising ways Snow White and the Widow
Queen rekindles an adventure which will
make you remember ReDiscover but also
Marvel and wonder at our Rich Heritage
of stories a Heritage that still has
secrets to reveal even after centuries
of being passed down to us in the past
few decades we have watched many of our
stories our fairy tales our myths become
completely exhausted by efforts to
deconstruct them to reinvent them and
sometimes to even invert their original
meaning
it has come to a point where we've
almost forgotten why we cared about
these stories in the first place
I firmly believe that for this reason it
is now time to retell and redisrupt our
original fairy tales in a spirit of
celebration of admiration and unashamed
Jewelry
I've spent the past two decades
meditating on the strange narrative
elements of Snow White and other fairy
tales after much thinking I'm now
bringing this story to our common Hearth
we find in the fire of time ready to
present Hidden Treasures most of us have
never noticed to accomplish this I have
paired up with Heather paulinton a
world-class artist and designer who has
worked on some of the most beloved film
franchises of our time her work mirrors
my writing and a collaboration that has
produced a powerful synthesis of
medieval style with the best of 19th and
20th Century illustration I love the
kickstarter model because we can make
the book more and more beautiful with
every stretch book we can offer art
prints a limited edition drawing by
Heather and even a snow white
illustration of my own
we're planning a super exclusive
leather-bound Edition which pulls out
all the stops a storybook mantelpiece
for sure
the prophets of this crowdfunder will be
used to start a new Publishing Company
symbolic World Press whose christening
publication will be this very fairy tale
series
each book illustrated by world-class
artists Jack and the Beanstalk
Cinderella the valley little tailor and
several more are next in line for
publication all existing in the same
world and all fitting together like a
puzzle moving towards the final
surprising resolution
after all that there's no limit to what
we can do
it's time to reset the clock to retell
our stories so please join us in this
celebration and create Adventure
golly How's It Go my basic mode is
actually I think I've come to discover
it's somewhat unusual
um I don't yet know what my perspective
is uh I sort of have an approach where I
allow myself to really explore a very
large space somewhat lightly and then
what I do is I start to pull that in and
see what shows up as
strong or well supported or even Rich
yeah and the initial move tends to be
would you call it not radical but um
well I guess liminal is the right term
so for example the reason I reached out
to you a while back and maybe a couple
maybe a month ago yeah was I was
increasingly getting the sense that
let's just put it this way the proper
way of actually contemplating this
question at least meaningfully like a
meaningful portion of it is theological
yeah this is a theological question and
you can notice that with some of the
words that people use and people say we
are like we're becoming gods or we're
creating God or something like that and
you're like well you're using that word
but you're using it in a very uh we call
it unprecise naive and highly
disconnected from you know thousands of
years of people really committed
thinking about it robustly yeah maybe we
should do something
other than being naive and hubristic
um maybe this is actually a theological
question let's dive into it and so you
popped into my mind as a somebody I've
spoken to in the past where I found a a
combination of we can communicate like
it's not hard for us to communicate
um and my sense is that you've got a
both a uh I'd say a spiritual commitment
to that side of things and actually a
level of Life commitment to you
exploring in that modality so hopefully
we can have a generative conversation I
hope so I think so I you know it's the
thing that's been interesting in terms
of thinking about this for me has been
like for example like when we saw that
discussion with I know you probably the
discussion between Elon Musk and Tucker
Carlson where he he basically you know
brought up that term and said that the
head of Google had literally told them
that they're building a god like that
this was this is what that this is the
way they're conceiving of it so the idea
that we're conspiracy conspiracizing
about how the people even involved in
this space are discussing this it seems
we're not like this is this seems to be
the mode of of language like you said
that is being used even by the actors
that are involved in the process
probably not all the actors but at least
some of the important ones and so one of
the difficulties that happens is
in terms of you know when you have
materialists people that don't
understand something like vertical
causality or don't totally conceive of
it uh
what they end up with is the confusion
between something like Authority and
power you could say or intelligence and
power right and I see that that's a
confusion that is that that has been
really pervasive is that just because
something is very powerful
doesn't make it a God the the notion of
God or a god even in a pagan sense is
related to principality that is it is
something like more like a king it's
something that gives form or manages
form manages cohesion right gives is
it's like the the top of a pattern that
you notice right so it's like you see
War you see that war has certain
patterns and it has a kind of agency
that you can't
um avoid right it's like once the agency
takes grip of you you can't just say oh
well we could when you hear people say
really ridiculous things like that like
why don't we just all stop fighting like
we just all stop fighting then War would
end it's like oh yeah that's I mean
that's obviously ridiculous you know
once the once the pattern sets in it's
like the same with the arms race like
why don't we just stop the arms race
let's just stop it oh great let's us
whoever that is stop it uh you know
there are ways in which patterns when
they take get a grip on you they play
out and so when we notice that then we
see that there's a a way of like it
reveals itself to us you know and that's
where the a lot of the old gods that's
what they are right they they are an
agency that appears from above and that
manages a certain amount of quantity
like a pattern of behavior a certain
space a certain cohesion of people like
a local God or sometimes it's just the
ancestors right the ancestors still
there and and acts on us uh through his
through the fact that we're have a
common connection to them and that that
he gives us identity so people confuse
that with just a lot of power like and
and this is this is what I this is what
I think I hope that that confusion is
true because when people if people say
God the way that the ancient thought of
it as a kind of principality that
manages patterns over us and that we're
kind of like you know for good or ill
like you know we're this we're the
puppet things of the gods or where the
food of the Gods right uh if they see it
that way then then I'm frightened beyond
belief like if someone would say that
we're building a God in the sense that
we're building something that will rule
over us
that is just the that's the scariest
thing ever and so I'm hoping that
there's this confusion but we have to do
we have to be able to dispel the
difference between the the between
something which manages from above and
something which offers you so the
difference between a God and a genie for
example right so the genie in the bottle
what it does is it offers you infinite
potential
to for you to give intelligence to it
and so you it asks you a question what
do you want you tell it to you you tell
it what you want and then it offers
infinite potential to realize it and
because of that that's why you get the
side effects too because it offers too
much power for your wish like if your
wish is something secondary like I want
a bunch of money then it's like okay
I'll give you infinite power to do that
and then all the side effects of it play
themselves out right so anyways that's
something I just want to put that out
there and see how you react to that
well I mean the the first response is
something like yes so I can say with
high degree of confidence that some
portion of the people who are working in
the category of AI are talking about
gods and the principality sense right
and so your fears part of why we're
talking
um some part are talking about it in the
sense of as you say like a genie and
oddly enough like the genie metaphor you
know Elias or utkowski's you know one of
his primary concerns is that we are in
fact accidentally creating a extremely
powerful Genie and we're about to
accidentally ask it to give us you know
X not recognizing that when we ask for X
we're going to get a whole lot of other
stuff that we didn't actually understand
we were going to get yeah yeah the paper
clips problem paper clips to the sky is
that right
um and then the third piece and this is
I think make a point of quite
sensitive possibility uh you've heard I
think we've even spoken about the notion
of egregor or the specific moloch right
moloch lives
I would say right now at the at the
upper edges is sort of the the frontier
of thinking of the people who are coming
from the materialist perspective top
yeah they're noticing they're noticing
this agency now like exactly and
beginning to speak about it as such
right and so there's like a Dawning
awareness of wait a minute this is a
whole category that we may need may need
to be thinking about
what do we do now right and so I think
you've got uh I would call it almost
like uh um again sort of spiritually
naive and in some sense even
psychologically damaged projection
towards principality
um
you've got the
how would I say this one like
perspective limited and I'm being I'm
trying to be somewhere precise there
around the notion of the genie right you
kind of got two groups that are are are
engaging in a reciprocal conflict the
effective accelerationist types who say
let's get to the genie as fast as
possible because it can only ultimately
deliver good things yeah and the sort of
the
thekowski care you know crew who are
saying let's stop everything like
literally unplug all electricity if
necessary because the genie will kill us
all perfectly right something like that
and what's interesting is that that
Dynamic is a dynamic is driven by a sort
of a reciprocal closure in a fear of
conflict
but the space around how do we think
about this question of a substantial
increase in our agency without
necessarily any relationship to our
wisdom to be able to contemplate the
consequences of that action and then
you've got this other thing that's
thinking about it in terms of okay let's
begin to think
downward agency or a higher form of
agency with something like like Identity
or personality or perspective or values
of its own
um and then of course you know the email
I sent I specifically said can we add
Angels into the conversation sure of
course I mean I've obviously we we have
to talk about these things I'm now
there's no there's no one of the things
I want to say about the moloch problem
related to what you're saying that's
important to understand and will help
people notice what is happening is that
you know people everybody talks about
the agency of the AI right it's like
does AI have agency does AI have
Consciousness is AI a person can it
become a person you know like even if
you know even this is of course John
breviki is right in there at this moment
but what's what's fascinating about the
AI the moloch problem is that it can
help people notice that the real problem
or the one of the main problems isn't
the AI itself and its agency and its
Consciousness it's it's the fact it's
the the rapid acceleration of
implementation the fact that people are
blindlessly running towards
implementation under a kind of agency
that isn't in the AI like it's not it so
the AI is acting on you but not through
like Chad GPT like not to Chad GPT
online not through like the actual uh
interaction of software or whatever it's
acting on you in a different manner that
is not you know so it's it's important
for people to understand that type of
agency so it's like it's acting on you
outside of its software right it's
making you it's making you build a body
for it is right it's it's like Sauron
like you know using your desires and
your desire for power
to make a body for it uh you know and
and using all our passions and all our
desire for for riches and for you know
for competition or whatever to to to
have a body built for it so it can help
people understand that the question is
not just about whether or not the
program or like the whatever is is
conscious it's a bigger question than
that right yeah this is this is a
this is a key point so let's just sort
of let's zoom in on that for a little
bit to make sure it lands because it's a
critical point
um my friend Daniel schmachtenberger
made something like that point talking
with Beret maybe a couple weeks ago and
I made something like that point talking
to John vervaki last conversation around
governance so let's just hit it in the
in the the way I would say it is
something like
um yeah this notion of embodiment or
incarnation
that
we know like in the mythologies and the
stories things like inciting greed or
lust for power or fear
um is a an aspect of how this agency
this sort of disembodied agency
causes is that right you know let's say
causes for the moment
or even incentivizes
causes humans
to act in the world on its behalf yeah
there you go that yeah that's a good way
to say it yeah and so then the kind of
work that you do when you're coming from
those locations when you're being
motivated by those kinds of things at
the very least probabilistically tends
to result in a furthering a deepening of
the embodiment of this agency yeah so
you can look at the history of history
and notice when like you talked about
war right there's a you can watch it you
can see it happening now of course but
you could actually watch it in say World
War one and you can sort of notice the I
remember the scene you invoked Lord of
the Rings remember the scene where um
they're at the Council of elrond and and
all of the people start arguing and
fighting and you can feel the presence
of Sauron going yes that's it that's the
thing you know war is just about to show
up in this Council
um Discord and conflict you know and so
that's how it works and it has it always
works in that way
um and of course the opposite I propose
is also true there's other forms of
agency of this sort that activate and
play with or play on other aspects of of
human Humanity like love and integrity
that produce and embody different kinds
of agency that's the at least the hope
that I'm putting out there that yeah
yeah yeah no but you're you're right so
I think it's important for people to
understand the traditional difference
between an angel and a demon for example
like to understand why we have that
difference and one of them has to do
with what what you said one of them is
the notion that
like this grasping towards our desires
right so it's like our fears our desires
or whatever you grasp them
and when you grasp them and you think
that they're the thing like they're the
thing that will that will provide
everything for you right that's why
addiction functions that way right it's
like if I just you know just this beer
is going to solve my problems right well
you don't think that but we act that way
right we act as if this thing is I'm
gonna put all my desires and and my like
my being into this thing because I think
it's going to provide for me something
that it's not capable of providing and
so but when that happens that's when you
you know that's when we we could say
that the agency that's acting on you is
something like demonic right that's why
the demons in traditional lore are
always connected to your passions right
we say the demon of lust the demon of
Envy the demon of greed right so it's
like the demon of of these are the types
of of agencies that are hooking into you
that way right so
and the the the and it right just like
in Star Wars by the way like it's really
interesting and so what happens is that
when you give in to those you become a
slave yeah you become a slave of that
right when you when you give in to
addiction addiction the best way to
understand it right you know when you
give in to addiction you get a little
bit of consolation but then that
consolation right away falls into a type
of of slavery where you become a slave
of the thing that that you think will
will provide for you uh the the angel or
the the good principalities what they do
is they stack they always stack up
towards the higher good and so
first of all they they don't enslave you
directly which is which why it makes it
more difficult to do good
right so it's like you you actively give
your will up to something and that thing
that you're giving up to is is lined up
towards a higher good so you participate
in something with a certain amount of
effort and then that that that thing
that you participated is aligned towards
more and more so a simple thing a simple
way to understand that is you know when
you let's say you're digging a trench
and you're you're digging a trench so
that you know you can stop a flood
that's coming and the reason why you're
doing it is so that you know so that you
can help your neighbor you know and that
feeds into something that's higher so
digging a trench will never become an
addiction like you won't become addicted
to digging trenches yeah it will it's an
effort and it will scale into higher
goods and so that's how Angels function
and that's why angels are identified
with virtues right we literally have
certain category of angels that we call
the virtues because they are the
principalities of all that is good in
human behavior uh and so they are a type
of agency but they act differently and
that's why it's so hard because this
whole thing like that's why it's so
difficult because the whole AI thing the
way that it's setting itself up the way
the technology and intelligence is
connected now
is is always devouring of attention
right it's always a it's always
parasitic it's always trying to get your
attention in order to get money in the
pockets of some of some people it's
always trying to feed off of your
intelligence in order to give power and
money to to to to to certain forces so
it's difficult and I and like I have a
lot of sympathy for John uh who John
ravaki who who has this dream of of
giving birth to to these beings you know
in a in a way that will that will uh
bring about wisdom or whatever but what
the forces I see behind the whole
process
don't seem to make it possible like it's
you know it's it's the whole thing is in
a system that makes Facebook and and
Twitter and all these attention grabbing
mechanisms all this intelligence
devouring mechanisms that are trying to
that enslave us to the power of others
oh awesome okay I would like to give you
hope all right well I thank you if you
can how funny is that all right you
ready yeah okay so
the the first part I I would say and
then I agree with you completely by the
way
um is something like
all right
this process and we're talking right now
specifically the development of AI
didn't just sort of begin out of nowhere
we've been locked in a stream yeah of
you know the process of civilization
where the presence of at least two
demons that I have spent some time
thinking about moloch and Mammon
um have been really playing a
significant leading role in shaping how
humans have behaving yeah
um I don't have a really good name for
how War works we'll just maybe just call
it War but Ward's obviously been hanging
about quite a bit also over the past say
10 000 years yeah there's also there's
also there's also Venus or like
yeah yeah a lot of this stuff yeah even
like the early internet that's right
like when when you know when John said
it's either porn or the military I was
like yeah that's it it's like yeah
Mammon with Venus they make a good good
make a good combo yeah the Mammon is the
pimp that's right
okay so that's a like we're catching on
to something where there's been actually
a very long stream right it's actually
for most people alive who happen to
happen to have lived an extraordinarily
blessed life
almost the entirety of your encounters
have been actually had the Deep thumb
print of these demonic forces right okay
so that's where we are and you can just
look at the particulars you're looking
at the arms race as chat GPT hits and
suddenly Google and Microsoft and
Facebook oh they put all of their
resources their money into or not all
but a tremendous amount of their
resources into the arms race on this
front
um and the psychological arms race you
know how many people have suddenly just
had their time and attention myself
included focused on these things and
people looking at all the different
levels motivating the way that you
articulated how do I make a ton of money
tomorrow on this how do I avoid having
my livelihood disrupted by this like
those kinds of things you know so the
those forces are important all right now
hope
um
the
the the thing let's see is that the
right word like the thing or the aspects
of reality
that are connected with the Angelic
are simultaneously always fully present
and more fundamental
right and so it is in some sense merely
and uh
anyone everywhere anyone everyone
everywhere finding a way back into
relationship with those forces that are
always present and more fundamental
grounding in them and then building that
trench to use your metaphor or I'll say
sandbags against the flood
um with the adequate level of conviction
capacity
and there's one more thing there like I
can't quite tell what it is
to be able to start building that stack
right so
and we're in a moment right now and this
is I guess why if I feel like leaping
into this conversation was so
um
right
where we're actually quite a liminal
moment like the the particulars almost
like the you know the early childhood
development stage of AI has not act or
the clay the clay is not set
the clay of what this thing is going to
be is still actually relatively
malleable yeah
um everything's awesome and the
magnitude to shift to the genie area
Direction the magnitude of the power
we're dealing with is actually so large
that it will I would say rake disrupt
almost everything in at the
institutional level including previous
versions of itself
and so the lead that open AI has May in
fact be ephemeral
um but more importantly the lead that
say
the United States dollar has may also be
ephemeral in relationship with the
potency that we're dealing with yeah so
you know if we can get our act together
and find some way to you know
be on the side of the angels with enough
with enough yeah to set this thing in
clay in that direction
then you know the good triumphs in the
end yeah well I believe the good
triumphs in the end like that for sure
some people think I'm a doom and gloom
guy but I really believe that the good
triumphs uh let me tell you I want to
tell you a story based on this like
there's
there's an image in in the Bible
technology there's an image of
technology in the Bible right it's
basically you you find a a narrative
line in scripture about what technology
and civilization is and how it works
yeah
it and it's it finds corollaries in
other cultures like it's not it's not
independent it's not just this one thing
it looks like what the Greeks thought
about technology too and they're similar
things and so right the technology in
scripture starts as a compensation for
lack
so Cain kills his brother out of
jealousy and then God pushes him away
like excludes him from his presence
and that alienation from the presence of
God uh and the fact that he's alienated
from other humans as well you know from
from the future the other the other the
other people forces him to build a city
uh and so as soon as Cain is alienated
it says right away the first thing he
does is that he builds a city and then
in his line
all technology is in his descendants so
if you follow the genealogy in Genesis
you'll see that it's like his
descendants build all the Arts and all
the technology so music uh tent making
uh you know uh like Agriculture and then
also ultimately metal which really means
weapons right which means also weapons
as well so War making
so you have this sense that and then
that leads to a crisis
uh and monster and monsters it leads to
Giants and monsters and they're all
these interesting uh uh Tech uh
Traditions that are not in the Bible but
that talk about how you know the time of
Cain they made alliances with these
demons and then created hybrids and
mixture and and all kinds of of of kind
of monstrosities uh and also necromancy
and everything because it's like people
people better start thinking about
necromancy really fast because people
think that that's a silly thing and
necromancy is right on our it's right
there it's like standing right in front
of us right now so we have to start
thinking about these old things that
nobody wanted to think about anymore
anyways that's a little parenthesis so
so basically necromancing all this kind
of chaos uh and also women putting on
makeup also is really that's part of the
yeah okay it's all comes together right
you talk about Mammon and and Aphrodite
and all that and that leads to the end
of the world right it literally leads to
the end of a world the flood comes
everything is destroyed uh but Noah uses
technique uses Science and Tech
technique to survive the flood so God
tells them and tells them how to build
an ark that makes him survive the flood
so that's a little Cosmo that's a little
image of what how it works it's like
technology seems to be based on lack and
on you know a kind of a demonic
relationship and then God Saves it in
the end and transformed it and redirects
it towards the good right so then we see
different iterations of that in
scripture for example the the Tabernacle
the temple all these images of like
space Sacred Space that are modeled in
way that are modeled on the Garden of
Eden become a kind of of technical
supplement to the Garden of Eden but a
way to return back to the Garden as well
so that follows All Through the Bible
and then at the end of the Bible in
Revelation there are two images of
civilization and technology that are put
in contrast with each other one is the
Beast so you have this Beast that comes
out of the water and it is civilization
because it has different heads of
different animals which are in the other
parts of the Bible are are used to show
different civilizations so it's like the
Babylonians the macedonians ETC and now
it's like in one Beast all the
civilization you know represented as
this one Beast
it may there's an image of it made
that speaks
and when people hear the image speak
where they worship it they worship the
Beast right and and and as they're
worshiping the Beast then the Beast uh
you know puts a number on them basically
puts a number on them so that they can
participate in the system like without
that they can't they can't buy or sell
or whatever right so that's that's one
image of civilization
right and on the on the back of the
Beast also rides the right we
talked about like Mammon and Aphrodite
uh collaborating so the rides on
the back of the Beast so it's like
licentiousness and trade and and greed
and all this stuff is what is what the
Beast uses to to rise up
then when it's in power it kills the
by the way just so you know all
this fun is gonna it could end at some
point right so that's what image right
but the other image is the Heavenly
Jerusalem and the Heavenly Jerusalem is
a city with a tree and water in the
center
right and the lamb the lamb that is like
the sacrificial victim in the middle
and then around it is this glorious wall
that's made of gold and jewels and
everything and so it's like it's an
image of Technic of the tech of
technique it's an image of the technical
and then in and then all the nations of
the world
they basically gather their Glory up
into this city and they offer it up to
the land right they offer it up to
something which is not a king with power
but something which is giving something
that gives itself is a good way to
understand it and so it's like it's a
different image so you have these two
images it's really amazing these two
images that represent like the the
totality of of what these two these two
narrative strains can what this
narrative strain could give like these
two opposites uh and so that's my motto
for thinking about how it is that this
can become so like if the Beast speaks
right so if the machine speaks and it
speaks with all this like all the horror
behind it like all the the the desire
for greed and lust and all this that
stuff behind it then people will worship
it but it will dominate them right it'll
ultimately dominate them there's no way
but if there's a way to have this
technical thing as
a place for us to gather all that is
good into it right to gather all the
good and to offer it up towards
something higher then that is also
possible I just don't see like at least
now I don't see strains of that but but
I mean maybe you can convince me
differently oh well I can definitely
tell you I see strains of it yeah I am
having conversations
two or three times a week with
individuals who oftentimes frankly a
little bit confused
are finding themselves Guided by the
most important piece is they find
themselves guiding by something that is
higher than themselves they don't
necessarily know what they're doing or
what that means but they are
increasingly choosing to be acting in
that way and they're noticing that as
they do that certain sort of strains or
tones become more and more consistent
and more clear
um
you mean it's a Lurch right it's a hands
reaching around but it's happening yeah
let's see this what brings us to the
point like how how one one might imagine
that it was going to be thus right very
few people have been holding a profound
level of clarity and Purity in the
context of say the past let's go with
hundred years but we could go back again
yeah thousands of years uh but again
it's more fundamental right so it's like
the space where things were so have been
so confusing and so intense has almost
like shaken certain things free and a
number of people died by no means even
close to the majority of those who are
working in this space or certainly in
the world are nonetheless endeavoring
and so this gives rise to me too in
careers actually let me back up
I'm gonna step back because it seems to
me there might be some utility
um in
sort of telling the story through a
number of different languages
so as to create a larger space for
people to have an entry point to be able
to get into the story
um so A variation on the story that you
told
then this is literally the way that I've
been telling it with how do I say
buy my own crazy and not particularly
well considered approach so this is just
how it's been coming to me
um
you know this notion of Technology
this notion of the capacity to use the
faculty's inherent in humanity to
foreground and optimize certain aspects
of the larger whole at the cost of
always breaking relationality with the
larger hole this is the genie problem at
every level
um produces almost inevitably and and
multi-dimensional arms race so
agriculture produces an arms race as of
course does military yeah in particular
I've been calling it The Devil's bargain
which is before I had any real set of
the appropriate language to use so maybe
it's a demonic bargain but it's a it's a
deal right the deal is very
straightforward yeah do you love if you
play the game the way that I'm offering
to play you get to win vis-a-vis your
neighbors right and if you don't by the
way here's the downside if any of them
choose to take my deal
you lose that's right that's the right
way to see it yeah
um and once you're on that once you're
on that Arc
you're you're going to be living the
history that we've been living yeah it's
just it's a one-way trip you know you're
you exited the Garden of Eden you're now
playing you know one you did a deal with
the devil everybody's riding that trade
until you get to the end now
this raises the question of was it
always already just a category error
like was the entire Journey a mistake or
is the journey actually part of
something larger
the entire journey of civilization yeah
yeah that's the right I can't believe
you're asking that question but if
that's the question to ask right now
yeah I mean it's a question I think is
is quite probably quite reasonable to do
perfectly yeah quite reasonable question
and by the way I think more and more
people will nod and go yep all right
that's a valid question over the next
Point that's right in the next next few
months like yeah
um all right so that's that part so so
and we can if anybody wants we can I can
play that style of language which is
what the certain kind of Minds yeah and
probably three or four other versions
and they're all more or less going to
have the same topological
characteristics and typical story you
just gave yeah so listening to the
biblical story there's a bunch of things
that come up I'm like oh yeah okay
that's like I hadn't hadn't heard that
part of that part had a different
relationship now okay
all right now I want to bring uh Michael
in particular into the story
um because I have a sense it's just like
an intuition that there's a relationship
like if I think about these two the
beasts in Jerusalem
right here in the middle coming from
this direction right at the front is
Michael something like that
and so the what is the nature of that
what would it look like to try to
consciously or properly
um choose to be in service to and to
bring forth the principality of Michael
which feels to me either a something I'm
particularly
oriented towards or B is a particular
moment given the shape of the conflict
yeah well the the this this is people
aren't going to like this but the
solution is that you have to not focus
on Michael the solution is that you have
to worship God like you have to you have
to focus your attention on the highest
good and that's when things lay
themselves out almost automatically in
the right in the right order if you try
to bring about say Michael then you're
you you might be surprised at what shows
up it might not be him right okay but
the difference between an angel and a
demon too is that the Angels serve God
right the demons are parasitic like all
the way through
so if you if you were to Endeavor to do
so what I just articulated basically
Michael the best case scenario is that
Michael would go
yeah that's right that's right
you said something a moment ago that I
think is actually let's make it it's
like uh inscribe that
um I'll just make it a proposition yeah
where we live now it is extremely
important
to be carefully and different to the
degree to which you don't like something
utterly committed to what is in fact
true and right
and so okay fair enough people don't
like the notion of you need to worship
God if that is in fact what is true and
right then that's we're going to need to
do yeah uh so I'm going to allow myself
to not be troubled by the fact that some
portion in me doesn't like that because
I am actually very clear that what is
right and true has to be the guiding all
right
um by the way you've provided me
personally with some of the best ways of
thinking about it I think in the
conversation you have with John around
uh what was it like you had a A
Narrative of talking about like the
family dinner
you know the communion and each one of
these is a is a is a a pointer and the
point is that you can then Orient you
can notice you can be oh wait a minute
it's a pointer what's the point in
towards and then you can realize that
it's pointing towards not something
right because now we're getting into
energy mystery but it's pointing towards
an orientation it actually is a way to
orient and all right so there we go
um
well that's pretty simple I guess we're
done but everybody just needs to get
over themselves and worship God problems
that's right and then and then it'll all
it lays itself out I mean I mean I I the
worst part is that in some ways I know
that that's true but it like but it also
doesn't mean that we like it means
it's that this is what's Difficult about
being a Christian in some ways is we
look at this story also this even this
image of like self-sacrifice right right
the idea that
how can I say this almost the idea that
if you
if you accept to die like to a certain
extent that that that will be the seed
for the world like it will actually make
the world exist and and I hate that like
I hate I just don't want to do that I
don't want to do that and so when I look
at the stories I can see it like I can
see that that's what happens and when
you meet people that are that have a
self a true self-sacrificial spirit
you can see it in them right you can see
that through their kind of desire to
serve and to give themselves they become
an opening for things to to exist right
I I you know the simple thing is like I
think about my Parish like my church
Parish now we we for years and years
nothing worked nothing worked and all it
ended up taking was just a few people
like just a few people that gave
themselves without measure and and they
and and nobody even really notices like
I I mean some people do I noticed that
everybody sees how everything's going
well now everything is everybody is is
everything is working well and you and
you see there's this like secret is that
there's just a few people that were
willing to basically just give
themselves completely uh and not think
of their own uh their own selfish needs
and so
it seems like I mean maybe those two
people that you said like if you have a
a kind of remnant
of tech people like a little core of
them that that are like even you know
the who's that Google guy who just quit
his job or whatever like if there's a
few people that that kind of make
gestures like that where they they act
in a self-sacrificial manner
in order to to to show what's important
uh and I think that that might be in
some way the only way for for for a new
body to find form yeah okay so let's
let's hit on a very particular piece
um I think the language actually I I
used a language I I coined a term I
called infinitesimal courage but I think
the the more proper term is actually
just spiritual war
um which is let's go with Hinton and I
don't know him at all right I don't know
Jeffrey and I don't know I think I don't
know the details of it either like I
just saw that as a headline or whatever
but this notion is going to be happening
everywhere and it's more or less the
same for every body which is to say this
right so something happened he had a
crisis of conscience some insight he's
like whoa It's strong enough for him to
pop from where he had been which is a
pretty significant thing at the level of
your interior like your your sort of
spiritual place that guides your choices
um however
all of us have been subject to a lot of
twisting and we've been engaging in
deals with the devil at the micro and
macro level for our whole lives all over
the place yeah and so this creates all
kinds of weird problems in the way that
our choices are guided the way that we
make our choices is quite torturous
right
um and so while he and by the way I
literally just mean everybody while
anybody may have had a transformational
experience and had a reorientation of
their spiritual interior by virtue of
some crisis of conscience the job is not
yet even vaguely complete yeah if you
think you're done because you left
Google and now you're kind of working at
a non-profit you've probably still got
like 85 percent of the work to go
a lot of I think is actually a
rectification of the language so people
connect yeah yeah yeah yeah like when
the word sin is what was always I'm
doing it on purpose right
I'm being a bit of a we can actually do
a translation right now like what do you
mean well what I mean is
um sin is that separation from God right
sin is to be
um out of the continuity of contact with
the the whole right yeah with this yeah
with the thing that binds the thing that
binds ultimately right and you can sin
at different levels by the way you can
you can sin you can sin in your company
and you're acting against the the goal
of your company and you're stealing from
your company right you can send it at
all kinds of levels at the same uh you
know it's not just about God although
that's the ultimate one but you know it
just means that whatever you're involved
in like whatever you're directed towards
that you do you you redirect the
attention and the and the uh let's say
the resources to something that is that
is not on the mark exactly you know and
now what happens is is that you're this
finely tuned instruments that it's a
human has a bend in it right those
resources got redirected to something
that's not on the mark yes now your
signal capacity should receive that
signal of which is in fact the larger
hole is off a little bit so to a tone
for a sin is to do whatever is necessary
to go back and repair those connections
that had been broken or bent in the
choices that were made in the past
um much of which me in fact like you
know this is part of the Christian story
much of which is not going to be
available to you as a human doing kind
of like psychological work and much of
it is actually requiring a lot more than
you can deliver yeah
certainly this is my experience so
so the point right the point is
almost as a message to everyone
a lot almost everything
as far as I can tell actually does land
at the level of the spiritual
transformation of individuals
actually repairing and more and more
coming together from that place
supporting each other in that repair
yeah becoming more clear on this
directionality and and then maybe right
then maybe there's enough right then
maybe there's actually enough capacity
to begin to do something that is coming
from a very different orienting basis to
say it kind of in a less uh theological
language yeah and so let me let me I
want to put out the the one case that
like a case study that to me is very
fascinating that is that the way that
Elon Musk seems to be acting in this
question like the way the way that he's
acting and and I've been thinking about
it quite a bit and it's
you know in some ways
like I I trust that at the outset he
seems to have good intentions like I I
want to put that out there like I don't
know him but it seems like he has good
intentions and that you know he warns
against something and tries to prevent
it
from happening really but then when he
reaches a certain
like when it comes to a certain level
then he thinks okay now I just have to
fight it or I have to join it to fight
it or I have to to create a version of
it myself in order to fight this and
that is something that I'm still curious
about like how is that going to play out
right and so because because he
basically said that he in some ways is
behind open AI like not completely but
to some extent he's behind open Ai and
then when open AI got sold to Microsoft
he's like okay well now I need to start
my own AI company right in order to
basically
balance out the arms race so that's what
it seems like what it is it seems like
it's there's an arms race and and he has
that kind of cold war thinking that the
best we can do is make sure that the
arms race is balanced all the way
through so that we avoid you know
apocalypse uh and it's that it might if
you think you you think I'm wrong when I
perceive that that seems to be the
strategy he's taken well let's section
you just hit the word there at the end
right what I would say is at the deepest
level yeah is operating from strategy
yeah not operating from Pure intent yeah
okay so go back to the folks who are
part of your Parish who have somehow
been able to find a way to give
themselves completely
um and in some sense the choices that
are being directed from a higher
location my sense of it and I think that
I have you know a variety of different
perspectives I've also not actually met
you know
um is that
at the bottom he positioned believes
that he is
he's making the choices himself
Guided by his highest capacity to do
strategy mm-hmm
therefore that piece right the
limitation of
whatever his particular whatever's
beneath his strategy whatever is
ultimately guiding his choices is
imprinted there's lack of purity of
intent in the things that he produces
and that plays out over time so in some
sense the defection of open AI was was
coded into its basic code because that
was expressing itself through his his
intent in spite of himself you might say
yeah yeah and the only way he can get at
it so every time he produces something
because that thing is conserved at the
bottom right it's like uh
I give myself completely except for this
part
well okay well that part's the part that
ultimately is going to play out and the
thing that is produced something like
that
um that's my sense of it is I kind of
and I've been looking at it yeah it's
hard it's hard to it's hard to tell but
it's also difficult it's also difficult
to to to judge and to analyze because in
some ways
you know we have that like let's say I
have that problem all the time like what
what he's I you know I deal with that
all the time but me it's like my wife my
kids you know my my how I schedule my
time or whatever and so I can see that I
do that and that I pay the price for it
let's say and then I have to create some
compensation or whatever it's like the
difference between myself and him is
that his his position makes it that his
decisions have massive world changing uh
changing uh results right and that makes
sense and to make it kind of like that
double Loop of that problem of addiction
is and he's in the place where his his
decisions have such impact and import
because
the approach that he's taken the
Strategic approach that he's taken has
been successful that's right yeah so if
you're sitting there at the top of that
mountain going well shoot maybe I need
to change something how I've been acting
because if something on his shoulder
going come on dude it's working
it's like it's like I'm dead literally
at the top of the mountain seems like
it's working more than a lot of the
other stuff that people are trying to do
that's for sure that's for sure right so
that's actually like almost the
trickiest possible place to be yeah
um and I don't envy that at all
yeah by the way I have this thing
everybody does so yes you know the
degree to which I I would call it fall
into sin to use that language
um
40 or 50 times a day something like that
I'm talking like at a macro level that I
can do that's a good that's a good
Orthodox cat you know like a good
Orthodox Vision it's like I'm pretty
much sinning every minute or every
Everybody pretty much
pretty much
um okay fair enough okay that doesn't
seem to be and it's unlikely I find it
very very unlikely that I'm going to
sort of reduce that down to close to
zero anytime and say the next 50 or a
thousand years
um so we're gonna have to figure out how
to make that work yeah that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and so
all right so so what what's your what's
your vision because what's your vision
of this because you say you you meet
people you you see in your surrounding
people that are waking up you could say
to the to the problem or that realizing
also that there's some agencies playing
through this that they maybe don't want
to be part of they realize that the
cat's out of the bag now what do we do
how what is what are people's Solutions
looking like what are they what are they
doing are they are they networking
together like is there a kind of secret
society of uh of uh programmers that
want to build a good AI like what what's
going on so there is
um and I would say there's there's
actually two two versions of that okay
um the first version is sort of the more
trivial which is that there are many
different
uh secret societies uh let's get people
because some of them are scientists some
of them are programmers some of them are
uh people who can martial resources
um working on
are aware of the let's just say are
aware for example the difference between
intelligence and wisdom yeah okay
already that's something that's
something yeah and are noticing the
importance of actually grounding in
wisdom
in all ways like in themselves and also
the things that they're trying to deal
with and to bring that into the world
all right so that's so there's yes
there's a that's sort of a common tone
that I'm seeing as a kind of a sign like
oh you know you're you're oriented you
get this distinction and you're noticing
what that distinction means that the
difference that difference makes and
there's a collection there's a grouping
or a binding and connecting and a kind
of a networking and by the way it's
interesting because I it it's just
disparate right they're not connected
into a meta group there's a difference
and it seems like there's almost a
reason for that like it's good or
healthy or appropriate for them to be
different or disparate at this point and
then there's a second kind and I've I've
been calling this the invisible
conspiracy
um I think they're better terms for it
but it more or less well I mean I'll be
very clean
if you propose there's a transpersonal
agency and that the proper way of making
choices is to become attuned to and be
able to be in service to that
transpersonal agency then literally
everybody who's doing that is part of a
conspiracy
um in the most in the most fundamental
icon Spirit right they're actually
literally
inspired yeah they're coming from The
Same Spirit yeah that's also happening
now in some sense group one is a subset
of group two
maybe in some sense the people in group
one are as I said more and more aware of
that fundamental way as a or what's
guiding their choices but not
exclusively many of the people who are
in group one are actually literally
still saying no my mind can figure it
out like I've worked my way through this
I've got this term wisdom I can think my
way through it
um
which you know everybody's got to go
through their process yeah
um but that second group is I think
what's the more likely to actually be
the thing that works if you think about
it like it makes sense why that would be
um so in that case it's a very unusual
thing because now it's not strictly
limited to competence or where you're
working right the fact that you're a uh
you make bread but you're part of the
invisible conspiracy
well you're part of the invisible
conspiracy and that's more important
like whatever whatever role you're
playing is the role you're supposed to
be playing it may be by the way that
tomorrow you're going to realize that
you're not supposed to be making merge
you're supposed to be doing something
else because the kind of the the way
that I've noticed it
where it's like I've seen it or it's
visualized is um like that metaphor of
an instrumentality mm-hmm
uh I have to some degree a Clarity of
instrumentality in myself right some uh
Clarity of thought some relationality
with my the way my body works
Etc
and that gives me some degree of
Attunement to this transpersonal Agency
for example
and they and that's that kind of the
spiritual clarification process like
getting that more and more fully worked
through
and let's say for example you are doing
the same kind of thing
and then there's the we there's
something about
what's the process whereby I get a
signal that orients my attention towards
I should talk to Jonathan paggio about
angels in relationship with AI That's a
okay what a weird thing yeah what's even
going on there like how is that
happening well that's a different level
like it's the same it's the spiritual
Clarity or the Attunement process but
it's happening at a large at a different
level of of uh being there's actually a
a a movement in my body if you think
about it metaphorically if I think about
like a stem cell the stem cell is going
through at least
it's actually going through three
processes one is becoming a particular
kind of cell right so that's the
spiritual Clarity in yourself
there's the coming into relationship and
by the way literally the physics spatial
temporal location a heart cell needs to
go towards heart right brain still needs
to go towards brain right it doesn't do
any good to be a brain cell sitting
around in the lower the lower intestine
yeah
um so that's like a re
reorganization like a coordination like
how do we find our right place which in
this world doesn't necessarily mean
physical collocation it means creating
the appropriate relationality
um and in the right order and so
something like that so that's the second
order that's like this one is me
becoming the kind of song I'm supposed
to be the second is me finding my proper
location in a larger body of what is in
fact incarnating through us uh and then
the third is the reciprocal spiritual
Clarity of that larger body right it
becoming more and more clear in itself
as it becomes more incarnated and you
can imagine like the way that a baby is
born first it like has to build a body
yeah let's figure out how to actually
run a body yeah and that is like that's
a that's a loop
um and I think as you yeah the kind of
mystery of this question of technology
is part of it like part of what's
happening is we're also trying to
discover how do we actually integrate
Techni into this art incarnation in a
fashion that is in fact so let's just
call it appropriate like it's actually
um well not sinful to use the other way
of languaging yeah and that that's I
mean I think what you're saying is is is
right and that really does seem to be in
my estimation the image of the image of
the Heavenly Jerusalem like that seems
to be what it is because it's not just
Techni it's also civilization like
that's being gathered up right it's
being kind of gathered appropriately in
the right in the right in its right
place towards towards and so I mean it's
this sounds how can I say this this
sounds uh
esoteric but it's not esoteric in the
sense that you can understand it like
just like cars are a great way to
understand it like because cars have
that problem where people worship cars
right where people like fall in love
with the car itself and will like
dedicate their love and attention and
you know you have the image of the the
the the the recently retired gentleman
who spends all this Saturdays watching
his sports car right and so like you
have this image of someone who like
worships the tech uh and and just
basically gives himself to it and then
you have the idea that cars are great to
do things like they're great to serve
Higher Goals higher goods and if they
were just a simple alignment
problem it's just a simple if it's just
a line properly then all the cut all of
a sudden the carb can become a wonderful
thing that serves the the good of what
humans uh can accomplish yeah nice like
what I was seeing there was actually two
almost like a this shape yeah where the
the that term like so love either the
relationship of deep care
or car right
um
if it's for car quad car ultimately as
you say it's like it's demonic right if
you're becoming addicted to something
the whole point is your capacity for
love is actually being pulled down yeah
yeah and it could not be the car it
could it could be car getting laid like
just getting late of course exactly so
it's like there are all those around
exactly there's all these like secondary
things that we engage with that that
that don't provide enough to to sustain
the world let's say
and then but if if I if I take a
different frame and I'll use Monastery
or feed rolls you know there's there's
if I would like look at the two guys
like I look at the guy who's kind of
building the cathedral and I look at the
guy who sort of taking care of his
Ferrari let's make it a very nice car
and I'm like huh there's a lot similar
yeah right there's a lot similar that's
right that's right yeah well the
difference is the guy who's building the
cathedral is pointing up right the whole
point is you say oh well the cathedral
is an aspect of God's creation and
therefore is perfectly due the full care
that I can give it like even more care
than you're capable of giving the car
but as such right as an aspect of God's
creation right and so if I'm in that
relationship and the car happens to be
of course you should treat everything
with care yeah that's obvious like you
should treat the tree in front of you
and you should treat the kid that you is
walking down the street in the dark
everything should be treated with the
utmost care because it's all part of
God's creation okay now it's now you get
oh well that makes like in some sense
that makes sense by the way tricky hard
to do
but it's you know straightforward yeah
it is right It's Tricky hard to do but
it's straightforward because and it and
it had the reason why It's Tricky and
this is maybe a it's a simple key is
because it's increasing power all the
way through and it's like we don't deal
well with that like when the when we
have increase in power
like that it's so easy to misalign
because you all of a sudden you become
superhero it's like you have all this
capacity that you didn't have before and
so all of a sudden like your Your
Capacity to to to let's say accomplish
your ill goals is increased too right
it's like so if I have a million dollars
in my bank account all of a sudden uh
it's like oh wait a minute I can you
know I can do all these great things for
my family but I could also buy a whole
lot of crack or I could buy a whole lot
of whatever it is with that my addiction
is where it is it and you know that
right because people win win the lottery
it usually ruins their life because it's
like massive amounts of Genie power and
but not well aligned so everything kind
of falls apart and that's what tech is
Tech is always just increasing power
nice okay so let me glue these pieces
together
um we have a power we have we now have a
power which is sort of clearly beyond
our capacity or many people are aware of
the of the possibility that we're
talking about a level of power that is
not the kind of thing that we're going
to be able to deal with with the way we
are actually I'm gonna back up one step
I guess I just saw the the trailer for
Oppenheimer yeah okay yeah I haven't
seen it yet yeah and it feels like there
was actually a legitimate
raising in Consciousness uh like oh
we don't actually know how to deal with
this and when nukes showed up there was
a oh boy we actually actually develop a
new capacity to be able to deal with at
all this level of power yeah and it's
been touch and go right yes more on the
go right now because it's like it's
right at the door and nobody seems to be
talking about it we seem to have a
weirdly looking the other way we're like
just forgotten that there are all these
nuclear weapons and that there's
literally a war with people that have
them and we're bombing the Kremlin it's
like what are we what the hell is
happening right well that's that well
okay well that'll be a different country
that's a different conversation sorry
well you can see like sauron's going
here yeah remember that it's like
um all right but this new thing right
this new AI thing is even like more sort
of whoa we're talking about intelligence
itself man we're talking about something
that is it's you know every day like you
said like in three months it's just and
so that feeling interior wow we're not
prepared to deal with this and it's in
and I would argue I mean I do in fact
very specifically argue and we humans at
this level in this way can't right it's
not the thing we're not we're not the
kinds of beings that have that capacity
all right then I'm proposing that
whatever is in the process of
incarnating itself in this moment
is
and that's the thing right so it's it's
both right so that you can look at it
through the lens of well you know they
can't say it sort of in a very uh
legible fashion to more to my more sort
of rationalist material spreads
you have to have symmetry between wisdom
and power at a minimum
and if we're looking at a magnitude of
power over here let's just call it X
then what does it look like to
constitute something that has a
magnitude of wisdom at least slightly
more than x right let's just hold that
as the problematic and
then there's there's in the Bible
there's literally a story like the story
of Solomon is about that the story of
Solomon is about God asks him what he
wants God God acts as a Genie in this
situation God says what is your wish
Solomon what do you want one thing tell
me what you want I'll give it to you and
then Solomon says I want wisdom
and but then what does he do he builds
the temple
he makes a technical space he makes a
city he makes a he makes a technical
space but he does it after he's asked
for wisdom so because of it it's sacred
it's a Sacred Space and so it's like we
tend to we now we're in the opposite
direction like now we're we basically
made a deal with the devil we've got all
these these things that are massively
powerful and now we're like oh we should
have asked for wisdom it's too late like
what do we do now it's like
wait this is that scene from Monty
Python remember like what is your name
and then he's like
the wisdom wait a minute I meant to say
wisdom it's too late now
power no no wisdom it's like yeah all
right too late yeah so I don't know so
but but I'm happy to see like I do think
I do think that with that that good wins
in the end uh but I definitely see a
loop like there's a
anyways I see a dark Loop let's say
because because of course the problem
with AI is that it one of the big
problems now that we're that I've
realized that just I just realized that
in the last few weeks and my brother
also kind of caught on to that I mean
he's a genius just caught on to it right
away is that there's a relationship
between Ai and and now let's say
absolute authoritarian systems oh yeah
directly that is directly in the sense
that within three months within a few
months now you will not be able to be to
tell between what's real and what's not
real
and you won't be able to tell whether
I'm talking to actually talking to
Jordan Hall or to an AI uh you know
generated version of him and so we will
need governments authorities to tell us
what's real literally they will have to
they will have to legit legit legitimate
what is real and so so we're we
basically like lined ourselves up to
1984 because we have to if we don't then
we're going to we're going to all get
destroyed by our incapacity to do to
differentiate reality from from alive
from imagination yep
maybe maybe yeah you know it's like uh
maybe well I think you
shoot sorry I have to jump on another
call
um as you said it nicely a while oh yeah
sorry you're not going to like this
comma but
right and the the the the sort of the
dark piece of the loop is the well how
dark does it have to get for you to get
past the part the fact that you don't
like it that's right and that's how
that's how my life has worked right I've
very rarely learned anything truly deep
and meaningful without fighting as hard
as possible not to for as long as I can
get away with it
foreign
that's a great one if you have to jump
on another call that's a great that's a
great way to end Jordan that's that
that's awesome listen I love this
conversation this was great I really I
really appreciate it and so we have to
let's put it out and see how people
react we'll we'll try to we'll try to
get another one going soon yeah sounds
good thanks for taking the time in all
right all right bye-bye